for the first time in a decade a new
resort on the las vegas strip will
welcome visitors
this summer today the much anticipated
resorts world las vegas announced
that'll open june 24th market on your
calendar
joe muller joins us live with more on
what's next hey joe
hey there kirsten well for months we've
watched work being done here on the
latest tower the las vegas strip and now
it's official resorts world today
changed these giant monitors to say
arriving june 24th
guests are now able to book their stays
at resorts world starting
at the end of june for the first weekend
rooms start at around 370 dollars
and go up from there you can also book
reservations for the new day club pool
and nightclub tourism and gaming experts
say this will change the northern part
of the strip and people visiting
say they can't wait to experience it
it's awesome it's very awesome i can't
wait for it to open up
for a long time it was just a shell you
know metal shell for
years and it's just nice to see this
part of town
you know building up again resorts world
officials say the project is on budget
and on time and they were confident
they'll be done by june 24th
they tell us most of the work inside the
building is done besides a few permits
needed
but they are now working on the
finishing touches outside also in the
works right now is
the boring company tunnel that will link
the resort to the convention center
underground now back out here live i
also asked about what will attract
locals and the representative from
resorts world says
they want to become the new favorite
spot for locals here on this strip and
they are working on some marketing
material
for las vegas residents reporting live
here near the las vegas trip jim mohler
8 news now